ende september will mehr als 1,3
millionen menschen in mecklenburg
vorpommern einen neuen landtag viele
leben hier vom tourismus und die fragen
sich natürlich welche pläne haben die
parteien mit dieser wichtigen branche
ich bin hannes palm ich bin 35 jahre alt
und ich habe mich mitten im letzten jahr
mit einem hotel hier in boltenhagen
selbständig gemacht
das hotel hat 16 zimmer und das ist
genau das richtige maß und wirklich
persönlich dabei zu sein und die gäste
mit namen morgens noch ansprechen zu
können mit nur drei angestellten stemmt
er den laden doch kurz nach dem start
muss er gleich wieder schließen sieben
monate shutter und ohne jegliche
einnahmen
leere straßen keine fahrradfahrer nichts
man hat strände für sich
das war eine zeit immer noch kurz kommt
hat okay so wäre deshalb alles ohne
gäste
wiederum kurze zeit später waren die
gäste aber immer noch nicht haben und
dann fragt man sich doch ruhig und dann
war bei vielen das erwachen das gesagt
wurde ja
wir brauchen doch die gäste wieder dass
sie zurückkommt das erleben dass wieder
austausch da ist die november und
dezember hilfe das waren ja nur die
ersten alle anderen haben bei mir gar
nicht zugetroffen und das waren die
beiden hilfspakete die
mir quasi im winter geholfen haben
ja land zu sehen dass man so nach dem
start nicht direkt mit der die segel
streicht team tut alles um in dieser
zeit sein personal an sich zu binden das
geht nur mit dem kurzarbeitergeld dass
das möglich war und dann gehalt
aufstocken und einfach halten also
weiter durch bezahlen die ganze zeit
dass das weiter läuft dass die auch zum
start wieder da sind
meine frage an die politik ist wie die
wirtschaftshilfen die jetzt an die
gewerbetreibenden und andere gezahlt
wurden refinanziert werden sollen was
dort auf uns zukommt und ein zweiter
teil der frage wäre wie die politik mit
dem fachkräftemangel umgehen möchte der
in der branche seit diesem jahr akut
herrscht über diese frage spreche ich
mit doktor jan müller von der uni
rostock er ist politikwissenschaftler
und kennt die wahlprogramme der parteien
was sagen die wahlprogramme zu dieser
frage jan müller 1 ist eindeutig dass
die fragen von refinanzierung der korona
hilfen nicht in den wahlprogrammen
thematisiert werden das ist teil des
regierungshandelns ich denke das wird
erst nach der wahl durch die regierung
dann werden da pläne und freiwillige
zahlungs zeiträume fest gesehen der
fachkräftemangel ist ein
im krassen gegenteil dazu ein thema was
alle parteien bewegt also ich fange mit
der cdu an die schlägt vor eine rückhol
programm also kinder aus mecklenburg
vorpommern die unser land verlassen
haben also die landeskinder möchte man
zurückholen die spd hat dies auch als
eine möglichkeit darüber hinaus wird
dann aber auch von anerkennung
ausländischer abschlüsse gesprochen von
der linken parteien die linke aber auch
die grünen werden die unternehmer auch
in die pflicht genommen zahlt ihr gute
löhne dann werdet ihr sehen dass ihr
fachkräfte bekommt die afd spricht dort
auch von qualifizierter zuwanderung für
die ard ist ist das auch ein thema und
bei der fdp um das abzuschließen da geht
es weniger natürlich darum die
unternehmer zu zu bringen bessere löhne
zu zahlen als
rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen in dem der
fachkräftemangel behoben wird durch
bessere ausbildung durch ja mehr
fördermaßnahmen und so weiter
wie werden die korona hilfen
refinanziert wer wird davon betroffen
sein die nächste regierung muss
antworten liefern der fachkräftemangel
ein dringendes problem im nordosten alle
parteien sind da dran doch die konzepte
unterscheiden sich
noch ein thema was den wählern hier im
nordosten unter den nägeln brennt ist
der anschluss an das schnelle internet
da hakt es nämlich noch in vielen
regionen das bremst die menschen aus vor
allen dingen hier auf dem lande
wir sind in rothenklempenow 1 600 seelen
dorf in vorpommern nahe der polnischen
grenze
hier warten die einwohner dringend auch
schnelleres internet ich bin gewänder
thaler ich komme hier eigentlich aus der
gegend und habe ihren start up
unternehmen gegründet wo wir bio vegane
lebensmittel herstellen und wir wachsen
immer mehr und kommerz unsere grenzen
mit dem internet
nicht eingerichtet ich war
zwischenzeitlich in berlin und dort in
kontakt mit der lebensmittelindustrie
und der wunsch war es essen herzustellen
was wieder natürlich ist wieder so ist
wie wir es eigentlich auch von zu hause
kennen
essen wo wir die gewürze erst anbraten
dann die gemüse die selber geschnippelt
sind auch einmischen und dann ohne
konservierungsstoffe oder andere
zusatzstoffe abfüllen und deswegen 70
ausland gekommen weil wir mit den bauern
zusammenarbeiten können um weiter zu
wachsen wir wollen mussten
warenwirtschaftssystemen zu legen und es
braucht so viel kapazität dass wir uns
im server hier herstellen mussten weil
wir auf dem externen server nicht
zugreifen können und wir sind jetzt fast
50 leute die müssen alle arbeiten und
brauchen internet und was kommt zu mir
ich so richtig
es ist schön über start-ups junge firmen
innovative ideen und von der stadt
zurück aufs land viel redet und es ins
zentrum und den fokus stellt aber wenn
die grundlagen dafür nicht geschaffen
werden dass man hier ordentlich arbeiten
kann dann kann praktisch sich nicht
entfalten und was ist jetzt ihre frage
an die politik mich würde interessieren
welche partei in mecklenburg vorpommern
sich wirklich dafür einsetzt und es auch
umsetzt dass wir schnelles internet und
ordentlichen handy anfang an jeder ecke
vom land auch hier ganz im osten
bekommen
und auf diese frage gehe ich weiter an
dem politologen jan müller von der
universität rostock herr müller was
glauben sie welche partei unterstützt am
stärksten den schnellen internet-ausbau
in ihrem programm verweist die spd vor
allem auf bereits geleistetes auf die
verteilten fördermittel und machten
einen zeithorizont aus von
1024 wo im ländlichen raum gigabit
anbindung zustande kommen soll die cdu
hat in ihrem wahlprogramm jetzt keine
genauen zahlen oder jahre genannt sie
möchten das gerne in einem ministerium
bündeln sie möchten dass mit blick auf
die wirtschaft ausbauen sie haben dort
als zielgruppe start ups und junge
unternehmen im blick die af den möchte
bis 2025 eine flächendeckende mobilfunk
lte abdeckung für mecklenburg vorpommern
erreichen die linke möchtest du dann
noch digitalisierung anders denken mit
einem digital konzept für mecklenburg
vorpommern an denen dann aber nicht nur
menschen aus der infrastrukturen
unternehmen sitzen sondern auch
wissenschaftler gewerkschaften und
datenschützer die grünen haben sich vor
allem den flächendeckenden mobilfunk
ausbau mit 5 gege sogar zum ziel
gestellt ohne da jetzt ein jahr zum
zunehmen und die fdp die fordert auch
den vollständigen gigabit auf ausbau
also private unternehmen oder gar
personen sollen mit fördermitteln oder
bestimmten programmen oder zinsfreien
krediten dazu gebracht werden
selbstständig in die netze zu
investieren
fazit viele parteien wollen den ausbau
bis 2025 auch auf dem lande
abgeschlossen haben ein ehrgeiziges ziel
an dass jungunternehmer govinda thaler
gerne glauben will er sucht derzeit
einen zweiten standort für seine
wachsende firma der soll allerdings
jetzt schon über schnelles internet
verfügen
ein anderes wichtiges thema im wahlkampf
für die landtagswahlen ist die bildung
wir treffen eine lehrerin die mit viel
eigeninitiative und privater
unterstützung die digitalisierung an
ihrer schule einfach selbst voranbringt
hallo guten morgen herr sprach herrschte
ich bin julia stadt lehrerin hier am
jungen bringt man gymnasium in güstrow
und ich unterrichte die fächer
sozialkunde und geschichte
ich bin hier an der schule als medien
bildungsbeauftragte verantwortlich für
die digitale schulentwicklung die ersten
klassen mit tablets kunden nur mit den
eltern und dem förderverein finanziert
werden julia h stellt hat sie überzeugt
hier den unterricht zu ermöglichen denen
es in anderen bundesländern schon seit
jahren gibt als ich angefangen habe als
lehrerin habe ich schon festgestellt
dass relativ viele noch so ist wie es zu
meiner eigenen schulzeit selbst erlebt
habe und da hatte ich schon das gefühl
ich möchte gerne etwas verändern und
damit habe ich dann angefangen und
versucht das lernen mit digitalen medien
aber vor allem auch das lernen über
digitale medien stärker in meinen
unterricht einzubinden viele denken ja
die djs die wachsen damit auf die können
damit umgehen selbstverständlich die
kriegen ganz viele apps für die sie sich
privat interessieren auch installiert
und können diese einwandfrei nutzen
medienkompetenz heißt nicht nur wie
nutze ich etwas sondern wie reflektiere
ich etwas auch kritisch das ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt wir müssen uns damit
auseinandersetzen woran erkennt man
fällt - wie begegnet man
beispielsweise sehr lohnend ist
tatsächlich auch zu erwähnen dass es
während der korona zeit um gelder gab
für unterstützung von sozial schwächeren
familien auch leihgeräte beispielsweise
zur verfügung zu stellen aber
grundsätzlich fehlt ganz viel zeit für
fortbildung fortbildungen vor ort
natürlich austausch vernetzung gerade
nach diesen langen zeiten der
schulschließung ist es so dass die
meisten kolleginnen und kollegen ganz
klar den unterricht als priorität setzen
das ist auch richtig und demzufolge
verlegt man fortbildung in den
online-bereich die flexibel vielleicht
am wochenende am nachmittag an abenden
umgesetzt werden können welche frage
haben sie jetzt an die parteien im land
welche perspektiven werden wir erhalten
für die schul und unterrichtsentwicklung
in form von kommunikation zeiten war
haben die wahlprogramme im angebot wenn
es um mehr zeit für fortbildung gerade
in der digitalen medien bildung geht
oder auch mehr zeit für das kollegium
untereinander die linke und auch die fdp
fordern eine absenkung der stundenzahlen
die in mecklenburg vorpommern auch noch
relativ hoch ist also von 27 auf 25
die fdp möchte zusätzlich auch noch mehr
lehrer einstellen also über den bedarf
einstellen da ist von 105 bzw und an
acht stellen abdeckung die rede und
diese zeit die man dann hätte die
arbeitszeit der lehrerinnen und lehrer
die könnte dann natürlich auch für
digitale fortbildung eingesetzt werden
die afg spricht von einem hausmeister
der für die technik zuständig sein soll
die cdu möchte die digital didaktik im
lehramtsstudium verankern das wäre jetzt
eher so ein langfristiger prozess der
kurzfristig vielleicht wenig helfen
würde interessant für mich also als als
punkt sind auch noch die grünen fordern
zum beispiel quelloffene software dann
wäre das mit ipads schon ein bisschen
schwierig mit apple und windows
produkten
die spd will flexiblerer
arbeitszeitgestaltung
bessere ausbildung von lehrkräften und
den breitbandausbau an allen schulen
fazit alle parteien haben die belastung
der lehrkräfte auf der agenda mehr zeit
für die digitale entwicklung heißt aber
auch mehr lehrerinnen und lehrer werden
gebraucht
eines der themen worüber sich die
menschen hier im nordosten gedanken
machen ist die energiewende ich bin hier
zu besuch in einem dorf wo sich die
einwohner vorgenommen haben ihre energie
selbst zu produzieren doch dabei stoßen
sie immer wieder aufführen
politik im landkreis mecklenburgische
seenplatte
650 menschen leben hier strom und wärme
produzieren sie so weit es geht vor ort
und mit erneuerbaren energien
[Musik]
mein name ist eigentlich schluss kann
ich bin 54 jahre alt bin von beruf
heilpraktikerinnen und lebe jetzt seit
zehn jahren hier in der gemeinde
beliebig und seit 20 19 wenn ihr auch
bürgermeisterin wohl ewig ist ein
bioenergiedorf die geschaffenen werte im
ländlichen raum sollten den leuten auch
vor ort zugute kommen und nicht dass wir
uns dass wir werte von außen in das in
die gemeinschaft holen also nur begrenzt
und da kam dann hier bauern mit ins
spiel oder die landwirte mit den dunklen
den kühen und die idee eben daraus
energie zu machen + natürlich auch
energiepflanzen wie man raucht sie mit
in die
biogasanlage eingeführt werden und dort
entsteht einerseits strom und
andererseits wärme und geht ins netz
oder bauhof damit seine stelle macht
seine melkanlage wird damit betrieben
und die wärme geht ins dorf und heizt
die häuser ein traum wäre eigentlich
dass man windenergie auch nutzen würde
das weiß dass man eigentlich aus dem
strom auch wieder wärme machen würde
leider ist das eben politisch heute noch
nicht möglich also dass eeg gesetz lässt
so was nicht zu mit anlagen gefördert
sind man müsste dann eigentlich ein
eigenes windrad haben und das können wir
uns als gemeinde nicht leisten
meine frage an die parteien wäre ein
welche partei unterstützt uns bioenergie
dürfe herr müller was glauben sie welche
partei unterstützt am ehesten
bioenergiedörfer ja ich denke wenn wir
uns das thema bioenergiedorf anschauen
ist das ein kleines puzzle stück ist es
leider ein bisschen der periphere lösung
der energiewende jetzt ist keine partei
dabei die sagen würde so eine kleine
lösung zu forcieren weil und es braucht
auch viele voraussetzungen das stichwort
klima klimawandel ist bei allen parteien
außer der afg angekommen es ist oben auf
der agenda vor allem speicherkapazitäten
das betont insbesondere die
spd aber auch die grünen die sich dafür
einsetzen dass die viele grüne energie
die er bereits produziert wird dass die
erstmal gespeichert werden muss und was
sagen die parteien zum thema windkraft
windkraft ist tatsächlich ein punkt wo
sich die parteien unterscheiden fds
gegen dem weiteren windkraft ausbau die
cdu möchte windkraft mit maß ansonsten
ist noch wichtig dass die
linken insbesondere von china
klimagerechtigkeit sprechen das heißt
sie möchten dass die klimawende sozial
gerecht verteilt wird also dass man
jetzt nicht menschen mit kleineren
einkommen darunter mehr belasten und
auch das ist ein thema für viele
parteien die relativ hohen strompreise
im nordosten
und gerade cdu und fdp
die ja eigentlich eher markt
fixiert sind
thematisieren das aber auch dass hier
ein ausgleich für die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher geleistet werden muss
fazit fast alle parteien schreiben das
thema energiewende groß kleine lokale
lösungen wie in bollewick werden dabei
aber kaum thematisiert anti oscar kann
nur hoffen dass auch bioenergiedörfer
von den plänen der parteien profitieren
bis zum 26
september ist noch zeit sich zu
entscheiden wenn noch eine andere
wichtige frage offen geblieben ist die
wahlprogramme der parteien haben wir
verlinkt und natürlich ist auch der link
zum wal mart für mecklenburg vorpommern
dabei
[Musik]